before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
if you're wondering why I'm in my David
Tennant cosplay when this video is not
about that it's because I was all set to
shoot a video with my more detailed
thoughts on the notion of my current
feelings about bringing back a previous
doctor to play the part again and then
then all this dropped and I need to talk
about this first and I'm not getting
changed
foreign
[Music]
don't worry that video on the
Regeneration is still gonna happen just
a little later now anyways so there were
a couple of things that got announced
and when the first one that well at
least the first one that I heard about
landed I thought I maybe I'll throw
together a short about that I'm not sure
I have particularly detailed thoughts uh
to cover and then I found out about the
second thing and I'm like ah all right
so there's well okay so there's kind of
two things that are the headline things
but it's the inclusion of a third thing
that's kind of how some of this was
delivered and announced that actually
made me want to talk about it so let's
what order do I do this and why don't we
just start with the logo we have a an
announcement of the new logo for Doctor
Who witches
decidedly old school it is very much in
the vein of the style of logo that was
done back during the Fourth Doctor's
Aaron possibly even I think it was
debuted during the Third doctors are if
I'm remembering correctly now it's not
an exact replica of the old logo but
it's clearly inspired by it and yeah I
like it I haven't liked every Doctor Who
logo I think if I were to pick one that
I didn't particularly like it was that
one that was being used for Matt Smith
Sarah that kind of had the DW try and
form the Tardis I didn't I didn't
particularly care for that one that was
moffets and looking back on the old logo
now during uh rtd's initial run as a
showrunner for Doctor Who it's okay it's
fine but yeah I like this now part of
this is I do like classic Doctor Who so
this is hitting that Nostalgia for me
but even if it doesn't hit that for you
I think it's just a nice tidy design
there's a reason that it worked back
then still works now so I'm not going to
do any kind of deep analysis on the logo
actually
I actually did do that uh for the one
that debuted for the Whitaker era I I
went on for like seven minutes about it
actually almost a little bit as a joke
I'm not doing that here but logo was
revealed I dig it very cool the somewhat
bigger news is that the BBC is going to
be partnering with Disney plus and
Disney plus is going to be carrying
Doctor Who going forward outside of the
UK and so looking over the announcement
um this is why I initially was going to
do a short on this there actually isn't
that much to report previously at least
in the U.S the Doctor Who uh brand and
the back log and the newer episodes
sometime after they aired was being
carried by HBO Max now it'll be on
Disney plus and Disney plus will be
taking it over in other territories
where it wasn't on HBO Max because HBO
Max didn't have the penetration that
Disney plus did that sounds dirty when I
say it that way anyways I'm rolling with
it so this doesn't strike me as that big
a deal but I think it's kind of worth
addressing because I can see a ton of
people like seeing the headline with the
words Disney and Doctor Who in it and
completely Miss what actually happened
or misinterpreted because we've actually
already seen this happen I had declare I
never did a video on it but I had to
clarify in multiple comment replies to
people after Sony acquired
um uh I think actually the studio
outright bad wolf Studio that's
currently handling the production of the
new uh Doctor Who material and a ton of
people thought Sony bought the Doctor
Who IP bought the bought the property
itself they didn't they bought a
controlling stake if not bought out
right the studio that's doing it but
that has nothing to do with owning the
IP and actually owning Doctor Who and
it's the same here Disney does not own
Doctor Who any more than Warner Brothers
own Doctor Who when it was being put put
out on the HBO Max platform this is just
about distribution rights that having
been said there's still a couple things
worth talking about the first is I'm not
surprised doctor who jumped ship off of
HBO Max that is quite literally a
sinking ship it has already been
announced that it's going to be merged
with Discovery plus into a whole new
thing that may or may not succeed on its
own merits and with David zaslub at uh
Warner Brothers Discovery making all
these harsh Cuts there'd be no assurance
that there would be any attempt to
actually leverage or properly push for
marketing on it and that is going to
bring us to the last thing that ties
into all of this that was the reason I
ultimately did decide to do this video
so there was a video that was put out on
both Instagram and YouTube featuring
shurigatwa sort of very actually in a
very casual almost offhanded way and to
celebrate the news that we'll be landing
on the BBC and Disney plus I'm here to
answer some questions let's go but
additionally
um just answering some general questions
about Doctor Who and I do mean very
general like premise level questions
about Doctor Who Doctor Who is a show
about an alien Time Lord with two hearts
who travels through time and space with
a human companion by their side in the
Tardis and the fact that that was done
and Disney's name was dropped in that
piece of promotion to me says that while
I do not believe that Disney is seeking
to actually own outright the Doctor Who
i p and I don't think the BBC would sell
it to them anyways
um depending on how BBC Works given that
it's publicly funded they may not
actually even be allowed to I don't I
don't know either way I'm saying like
maybe they can I don't I don't know but
I can't imagine they would actually want
to sell it but Disney does seem to
actually want to be an active partner
just like not not just what HBO Max did
which is we're the platform where you
watch this now hey come on over because
like they did make a deal it's not like
HBO Max did nothing with it it was a
little bit of a of a crowd of a jewel in
their Crown in terms of you know launch
lineup and bringing people in for Stuff
other than re-watching Game of Thrones
and watching that fall apart again so
the HBO Max did have some appreciation
of it but after that initial
announcement in series 11 they basically
just let it just sit there and that was
it the fact that Disney is partnering to
the point that Disney plus was part of
this initial push of marketing with
shudigato up front and center that
actually is pretty revealing about the
degree to which Disney is hoping to
become a part of The Branding so again
Disney does not own Doctor Who I would
be very shocked if they were ever able
to actually acquire it but that doesn't
mean that they don't want a strong
association with it because they feel
it's a brand that suits their portfolio
or it Taps into an audience that they
want to have involved with them that
they want to bring on board to see what
else is on Disney plus because you know
what theoretically if you had Doctor Who
fans who haven't really had a reason to
get Disney plus maybe they don't have
kids who need uh Children's
Entertainment maybe they don't have a
lot of nostalgia for old Disney stuff
maybe they're not into the MCU but you
know what if you can get people on board
by presenting them with an initial
property that they do love and you can
get some new people in well if you like
Doctor Who maybe you'll like some of the
Star Wars stuff there's a whole catalog
worth of stuff for you to look at and
maybe end up as a committed subscriber
even when there aren't new episodes
airing so this is fairly standard
business stuff but the degree to which
Disney seems to be going out of their
way to have their name very much
attached to the upcoming material that
feels like honestly a stronger show of
support and a stronger level of interest
in the property than Warner Brothers
Discovery Well it was just Warner
Brothers at the time ever showed with
the thing but I also want to come back
to shooty gotcha's
um little video answering questions
because as I said these were base level
like talking about just the core premise
in other words this wasn't a piece of
marketing aimed at existing Doctor Who
fans
this was a piece of marketing to pitch
the idea of what Doctor Who is to a
whole new audience
and I think it's very important that
they're doing that with gotchwa and not
with tenants because tenant is the
doctor we're going to see most
immediately he's who we're going to see
in the three specials we're getting next
year he's what a lot of the talk is
going to be about but it's not gonna be
him after that and this kind of shows a
commitment to not just assume that the
tenant Ron will definitely revive it and
we'll be fine after that no this is
showing preemptively an interest in
selling the connection of Shri gatwa in
this part and also presenting it for a
potential new audience which is
something that was done decently I would
say before series 11 premiered now I
would actually say that BBC kind of
failed to Market Doctor Who very well
after series 11. they did quite an
admirable job building up to the start
of Jody Whitaker's era but not really
after that and so if this can first of
all pull off basically what series 11
did it can make for a very strong start
but then if they have if they have
learned their lesson or if they are
willing to let Disney pick up the slack
and Disney's willing to do so on some of
the promotional side which their name
being mentioned in this video would
indicate seems to be uh what they're
leaning towards then maybe they can
continue that push so that it becomes
sustained interest and not just an
initial
um pop of interest at the start of the
thing of course there's also an argument
to be made that a bunch of new people
came in for series 11 and just didn't
stick around because I didn't like it
that's possible trying to parse the
demographics on that are difficult so
I'm not gonna bother I do not want to
get into a ratings argument again I hate
that nonsense but overall this entire
approach shows an understanding that
Doctor Who kind of needs to be sold
again and that David Tennant was very
much the move to bring people back in
who for whatever reason have fallen off
the show and not all of that was during
chibnal's run in whitakerzera to be
clear moffett's aerosol a massive
drop-off series 10 which I love but the
ratings just weren't there
they weren't so people were falling off
the show already and then the pop that
initially happened with series 11 didn't
stick so bringing back tenant is an
attempt to appeal to the old fans who
might well have fallen off during Buddha
because there are or may have fallen off
during Moffat Sarah and so that's their
hook that's to get them in to check out
the specials and I'll give sort of my
thoughts on all that when I get to the
video I originally got this outfit out
for to talk about that regeneration but
they're also already now doing the work
to uh introduce people who are new
because it's it's it's I'm not gonna say
it's impossible but it would be very
difficult to sell the appeal of tenant
to a new audience who doesn't already
know Doctor Who because
I have no doubt this is going to heavily
lean on existing knowledge and playing
to uh the presumed knowledge and
emotions and feelings and wants of the
existing fan base well maybe whether
current or have at some point been uh
the fan base of modern era Doctor Who
that's who this is for and so if you try
to pitch tenant to the new people who
aren't really into Doctor Who he's only
going to be around for three specials
and then he's gone and those specials
are probably going to be pretty
self-referential to the era prior to
that possibly even to classic Who that's
not gonna make for a great jumping on
point they may still be great don't get
me wrong jumping on point is not what
every single thing should or has to be
but that does leave the jumping on point
to make a lot more sense to push as a
concept with gotwa's era and if the
marketing is in line with the actual
creative decisions being done by by
Russell T Davies and his team then that
really does feel like a very wise
approach there seems to be a lot of
thought that is going into this and some
of it is reacting to the fact that the
bumpa in um viewers during Whitaker's
era didn't sustain that people were
already dropping off during Moffett this
feels like a response to that not
necessarily in a fan Pander way we'll
see if that ends up being the case but
these moves themselves don't have to be
fan pandering in you know a kind of like
just cheap way but they are trying to
appeal to different kinds of fans with
different aspects of this and they are
kind of pushing different things towards
different people again that's why the
Godzilla video is answering core base
level like every Doctor Who fans already
knows the answer to most of these
questions the doctor doesn't carry any
weapons just a sonic screwdriver for
fixing things and getting little tricky
situations but that's because the video
is not for them
it's to tell new people people who have
Disney plus people who may not be
anglophiles people who may not have ever
heard of Doctor Who to go hey this is
coming to a platform you already have
here's maybe some reasons why you might
want to watch it here's the idea doesn't
this sound interesting isn't this person
telling you he's going to be playing the
lead kind of charismatic don't you want
to see more and that's the flip side of
it because I mentioned how you know from
Disney's perspective bringing in Doctor
Who um you know could potentially bring
in new people to the platform but from
the perspective of Doctor Who as a
property
getting on Disney plus is big
because Disney especially right now is
the focal point of the biggest pieces of
American entertainment that there are
Star Wars the MCU the Disney brand
itself Pixar it is at the heart of this
and it basically owns America's
childhood
but Doctor Who isn't the childhood of
most of America
while Doctor Who has continued to get a
foothold and has a very strong following
in this country
it's not as ubiquitous here as it is in
the UK
but if you can bring it into a platform
that has a very sizable audience
that doesn't already know it or hasn't
had reason to seek it out and suddenly
oh look
I've heard of Doctor Who
oh it's on the service I've got now
hmm now
how will this affect quote unquote the
ratings who knows most streaming
platforms don't release their numbers so
you know any talk of ratings down the
line is going to be about the actual air
rating the uh ratings for the Airing of
the shows themselves on uh BBC channels
in the UK so again that's part of why I
don't like talking about them in an age
now where part of the value of a
property and part of the measure of the
appeal of a property is in streaming
which we only know what the streaming
numbers are if the platforms tell us
there are some organizations out there
that have their metrics and ways to kind
of roughly calculate what it might be
but you know the hard data they don't
have to provide and most of them don't
most of the time but overall this
this feels like a very concerted effort
and a very well thought out effort to
try and give this new era of Doctor Who
the best possible launch not only for
tenant who at this point basically has
already sold his uh specials just with
his appearance at the end of the power
of the doctor but also within I passed
that it's showing long-term investment
and long-term planning that frankly is
comforting and rewarding as someone who
looks at particularly the chiminal era
and feels like it was kind of flying by
the seat of its pants and their and as
much as chip Knoll talked about having a
plan and and all of it watching it
collectively it doesn't feel
particularly well planned both in terms
of the final product itself but
definitely in terms of the promotion
but this feels like there's more
planning more dedication and given how
much I love Doctor Who that's something
I'm happy to see
so there we go Doctor Who's Coming to
Disney plus Disney does not own it
don't go there uh new logo cool I like
it a little bit of uh shooting again
gives me no indication of how he's
actually going to play the part he's not
in character for this video but
he is Charming I'm here for that
what do you think about any of the stuff
I've just talked about whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it patreon is
what pays the bills around here allows
me to do this as my living into
um you know spend my day
churning out videos I hadn't planned on
in an outfit that I was wearing for a
completely different video because I
don't have to hold down a desk job
somewhere so any amount you can
contribute is of immense help and there
are perks for doing that but even if you
can't the likes the shares the
subscribes there's a whole bunch of new
subscribers here and I'm happy to have
you all of those help as well
But ultimately what I really want you to
remember
what I always want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
all right time to thank my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
lafolla Tarak the theme that goes doink
in the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters
emu delki leotha Boyd toy lowly Becky
Sparks for nobelax the poodle Zach
Bookworm Tracy scrabot angry casperal
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla Gourley Brendan
morose and TT thank you for your support
if you want to hear me try and say your
name while this little guy tries to chew
on my earrings well you can check out
the patreon or the support tears that
get you a shout out
thanks so much you are a pain in my butt
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]